Mit Wasser und Innereien mixt Sebastian
Lege eine Bratwurst, die eigentlich
nicht verkauft werden darf - aber fällt das
den Prüfern auf oder kann Sebastian
bedenkenlos tricksen?
Was in die Bratwurst darf, ist im
deutschen Lebensmittelbuch festgelegt, in
den Leitsätzen von 2016.
Darin steht, welches Fleisch zu Wurst
verarbeitet werden darf, auch der
Eiweißanteil im reinen Muskelfleisch ist
festgelegt. Er muss mehr als 8%
betragen.
So soll sichergestellt werden, dass nur
wertvolle Zutaten in die Wurst kommen.
Gute Regeln, aber werden die auch
eingehalten?
Wie gut sind die Kontrollen? Genau das
will Produktentwickler Sebastian Lege
testen.
Er stellt die Leitsätze für Bratwürste
auf den Prüfstand.
Im Großen und Ganzen könnte man da ja alles rein machen, was
man möchte. Man zerkleinert das schön
und hier noch ein bisschen und da noch
ein bisschen, am Ende des Tages ist alles
Püree im Darm. Sebastian Lege will heute
selber Wurst herstellen, mit unerlaubten
Zutaten und vielen Streckmitteln.
Ihn unterstützt Metzgermeister Frank Schwarz.
Heute wird's nicht einfach, wir wollen so
wenig Fleisch wie es geht in die Wurst
packen, danach wird's analysiert im Labor
und wir wollen sehen ob die uns auf die
Schliche kommen.
Das ist spannend, das
weiß ich auch nicht. Was kriegen die
tatsächlich raus. Erst einmal wollen sie
gestreckte Würste machen, mit ganz wenig
Fleisch und ganz viel Wasser.
Eine halbe Sau - nicht ganz. Da kann man
eine sehr, sehr gute Bratwurst mit machen.
Die Beiden verarbeiten Schulterfleisch,
Deckelfett und durchwachsenen Bauch
Das Fleisch ist einwandfrei.
Wir wollen es aber gen Himmel strecken,
um eine unverkehrsfähige Wurst zu
erzeugen.
-Aber die Sauerei machst du!
- Naja, natürlich.
Metzgermeister Frank stellt nur die
üblichen Zutaten zusammen.
-So, guck mal,
wenn wir jetzt hier
60% Muskelfleisch haben und 40%
Fett, denke ich sind wir ganz gut
dabei.
Das ist so die Menge für ungefähr 20
Würstchen á 90 Gramm
und da kommt jetzt lecker Salz dran.
Dazu Gewürze und frische Kräuter, einmal durch
den Wolf gejagt. Fertig ist das
handelsübliche Brät des Metzgermeisters.
Bis hierher alles so, wie es sein soll.
-Wir nehmen jetzt das als Grundbrät, das
machen wir zu unseren Kutter und
das pumpen wir gleich mal richtig auf.
Und jetzt fangen wir schön an zu strecken.
Eine gute Rostbratwurst besteht zu etwa
10% aus Wasser, zwei Hände voll
Eis reichen hier eigentlich völlig aus.
Sebastian Lege legt nach. Drei mal mehr
Wasser als erlaubt, damit das später
nicht aus der Wurst läuft, kommt viel
Phosphat zum Einsatz.
Und Soja-Proteinpulver - hat nichts in einer
Bratwurst zu suchen, macht sie aber
leicht und luftig.
-Tada! Frank, was sagst du?
-Es sieht aus wie Brät, ja
-Aber es ist Brei.
Probieren wir mal, ist ja nichts Giftiges
dran.
-Geschmacklich gut...
-Geschmacklich gut?
-Die Grundmasse sollte für 20 legale Würste
reichen und jetzt? Wie weit kommt
Sebastian Lege mit dem gestreckten Brät?
-Über 40 Würste.
-Wir haben mal locker verdoppelt.
So viel Wurst aus so wenig
Fleisch.
-Diese Würste schicken wir später
in ein staatlich anerkanntes
Lebensmittellabor, aber Sebastian Lege
hat noch lange nicht genug.
Wie viele Teilstücke bekommen wir in
eine Wurst?
Du wirst es mir verraten, aber es sieht
ja schon grausam aus.
In diese Wurst kommen Innereien und
billige Fleischstücke, Niere oder Leber -
eigentlich tabu.
Wenn wir das hier so übertreiben und das in
die Analyse schicken,
meinst du, die kommen uns auf die Schliche?
Bestimmt, also die müssen uns
auf die Schliche kommen!
In Deutschland dürfte so etwas nie als
Rostbratwurst verkauft werden.
Genau vor solchen gepanschten Waren
sollen uns die staatlichen Kontrollen
schützen.
-So, ab damit!
Gerade feinen
Bratwürsten ist nicht anzusehen, aus
was sie hergestellt wurden.
-Gut schauen sie aus, ne?
-Ich würde sagen optisch
erstmal schon ganz schön. kuppel lose
Skrupellose Hersteller könnten mit solchen Tricks
eine Menge Geld sparen.
-Also, das hat nichts mit unserer guten
deutschen Wurst zu tun.
-Aber Frank, man kann ja
mal sehen, mit wie wenig Fleisch man doch
'ne Wurst zaubern kann.
-Und reich werden kann!
Wie gut werden wir vor Fleischpanschern
geschützt? Wir schicken beide Chargen in
eine staatlich akkreditierte Prüfstelle.
Der TÜV SÜD ELAB gehört zu den Laboren
die solche Untersuchungen im Auftrag von
Herstellern und Handel durchführen
dürfen.
Wir beauftragen eine chemische
Untersuchung, gemäß der Leitsätze für
Fleisch und Fleischerzeugnisse. Dass
unsere Rostbratwürste gepanscht sind
verraten wir nicht, denn wir wollen
wissen: Was taugen die Qualitätsvorgaben
und wie gut sind die Kontrollen?
Seit dem Gammelfleischskandal von 2005
sind diese Fragen besonders wichtig.
Damals konnten tonnenweise
Schlachtabfälle importiert, verarbeitet
und weiterverkauft werden.
Die Behörden erkannten den Betrug zu
spät. In der Zwischenzeit landete das
Gammelfleisch unter anderem auch in
Bratwurst. Greifen die Kontrollen heute?
Dann müsste uns das Labor auf die
Schliche kommen.
Unsere Wasser-Wurst fliegt auf. Wer zu
wenig Fleisch verarbeitet und in eine
Kontrolle gerät, der wird entdeckt. Ein
Blick ins Ergebnis überrascht. Im Labor
wurde die gepanschte Wurst sensorisch
geprüft. Ergebnis: In Aussehen, Geruch und
Geschmack ist sie laut Prüfer produkt-
typisch. Und auch die chemische
Untersuchung ergibt keine
Beanstandungen.
Warum wurden die Innereien nicht
entdeckt? Das Labor hat den sogenannten
Beffe-Wert ermittelt. Der gibt den
Eiweißanteil im Muskelfleisch an.
Es gilt: Je mehr Eiweiß, desto besser ist
die Qualität.
Die Leitsätze für eine gute Bratwurst
fordern mindestens 8%.
Unsere Pansch-Wurst hat mit 13,3% sogar einen herausragenden Beffe-
Wert, trotz Innereien.
Das weist darauf hin, dass eines der
wesentlichen Qualitätsbeurteilungs-
merkmale, nämlich der sogenannte Beffe-Wert nicht ausreicht, um die
Zusammensetzung und die Geeignetheit
einer solchen Wurstmasse festzustellen,
denn offensichtlich hat der Eiweißwert
gepasst. Leber enthält selber ähnlich
viel Eiweiß wie Muskelfleisch.
Das heißt, das Labor hat alles richtig
gemacht.
Es ist der Beffe-Wert selbst, der für
eine Qualitätsbestimmung nicht
ausreicht. Dabei können
Lebensmittelkontrolleure sehr genau
herausfinden, welches Fleisch verarbeitet
wurde.
Zum Beispiel durch Gewebeuntersuchungen.
Nur werden solche Tests nicht
standardmäßig durchgeführt, warum? Das
Ministerium teilt schriftlich mit: "Die
amtliche Probenahme bei Lebensmitteln
und deren Untersuchung erfolgt
risikoorientiert, das bedeutet es wird
gezielt dort kontrolliert, wo Verstöße
wahrscheinlich sind."
Bedeutet: Untersuchungen auf Gewebe werden nicht
regelmäßig durchgeführt, sondern nur im
Verdachtsfall und der Beffe-Wert allein
ist zu ungenau.
Das stößt bei Verbraucherschützern auf
Kritik.
Warum spezifiziert man nicht so
eindeutig, dass in den Labors auch auf
solche Bestandteile wie innere Organe
untersucht wird, wenn es um eine Bratwurst
geht, die ganz klar aus Muskelfleisch und
Fett zu bestehen hat.
Große Wurst-Skandale wurden in den
letzten Jahren nicht bekannt, weil die
Kontrollen aber unzureichend sind, bleibt
uns Verbrauchern wohl nur zu hoffen, dass
kein Hersteller panscht.
Wo kauft ihr eure
Bratwürste am liebsten und worauf achtet ihr?
Sagt es uns in den Kommentaren.
Und wenn ihr noch mehr über euer Essen
wissen wollt, dann abonniert die ZDFbesseresser und schaut in die nächsten
zwei Clips.